hey guys it's Jenna here I use someone
that would skip your warmup and also
cooldown well guys it is extremely
important to get your warmup done before
your workout
warming up will help you to slowly
increase your heart rate and also blood
circulation in your body it also helped
me to loosen up your joints and prevent
any unwanted injuries after your workout
you have to cool down and bring your
heart rate back down this will help to
relax the muscles and also help with
quicker muscle recovery so it doesn't
have to be long I'm gonna show you a
really quick five minute warm-up and
also a really quick five minute cooldown
so do this warm-up before your workout
and also and it with the cooldown right
so the first part of the warm-up will be
is some really gentle cardio body weight
cardio just to get the blood in your
body flowing and we will end with some
dynamic stretches okay so each workout
will be for 30 seconds long so let's
start with jogging on the spot so just
gently jog on the spot and just really
breathe in and breathe out okay nothing
too intense it's just to really get your
legs muscle ready
and also just loosen up the top really
gentle jogging on the spot if you do
have knee injuries then what you can do
is just march on the spot okay choose
your option so gentle jog on the spot
breathe in and breathe out and the
second workout we want to move on to
jumping jacks okay to really stretch
your arms as well so jumping jacks again
these are all part of the warm-up so out
and end remember to keep your knees bent
slightly okay really stretch up and feel
your shoulders and your arms working as
well good keep going this is only your
first minute
by now you should feel your heart rate
that they increase and slightly next
workout high knees okay so bring your
knees up and just tap and feel your
quads your hamstrings all starting to
really getting a little bit tired and
you should feel the burning sensation
Islam so bring it up and point it down
good and the next workout will be a butt
kick
alright few more and let's get into butt
kick so reverse and just kick back okay
reverse and kick bring your heels to
your butt good and just relax the upper
body but cake my heart rate is going up
and panting and this is how you should
be feeling as well good but kick whoo do
your heart rate remember paced breathing
and the next will be cross kicks okay
so just then I'm out I want you to cross
and reach good this is to stretch your
hand drinks out good so keep your hands
by your side and bring your legs to your
hands good cross and tap cross and touch
if this is too difficult then you can
bend your knees slightly
good for your hamstrings being stretched
out and we want to move on to some
really gentle squats
should it width apart toes points are
forward and squat good and just give me
a nice squat the first view wrap will be
tougher but the more you do it you will
feel that you can't go deeper okay so
squat deeper and go lower remember to
always keep your chest up right good
feel your butt muscles squeeze it right
at the top very good squeeze it last one
and now let's get into a lunge
and reach good again working on your
lower body opening up the hip flexors
opening up the hips and also opening up
your chest and reaching up good
alternate very good reach down reach and
look up feel your lower back being
stretched out at the same time nice few
more good keep going and now let's get
into dryness down onto the floor again
opening up the hip flexor and stretching
on the inner thighs alternate reach and
feel your inner thighs being stretched
out look up and you will feel your back
and your lower back as well
keep going nice few more breathe peace
of breathing this is just your warmup
and the final one will be enjoyable so
start right at the top okay I want you
to slow the inch forward keep your knees
straight okay it's the stretch your
hamstring reach at the plank go back
keeping your knees straight and come
back up good let's go again you reach
forward leg straight knees straight to
your hamstrings into a plank position
and go back very good up let's do this
for one minute
keep going stretch out and go back
straight up and keep going
give me a few more up and back down
very good into a solid plank your upper
body strength and back up if you want to
challenge yourself you can even do a
push-up right at the end so well done
guys
that was your five-minute warm-up now
you can go and get your entire one hour
or 45 minutes of solid workout done okay
drink some water and get your workout
time well done on your workout your
heart rate should still be slightly high
so let's cool down and bring your heart
rate back down okay so let's start with
the first really gentle stretch which is
a Child's Pose so spread your knees
slightly
okay sit on your back and just stretch
it out and just relax cooling down it's
all about bringing your heart rate back
down okay so no stretch just relax
breathe in deeply and breathe out feel
your back being stretched out and just
extend and reach as far forward as you
can okay very good
and the next work that we want to get
into Cobra
so lie on your chest hands by your chest
and just push up and look up again no
tension it's all about relaxing no
tension on your body at all and just
reach up squeeze the lower back roll
your shoulders relax your shoulders push
your shoulders down look
stretch good and next let's get into
downward dog
okay so Pike your butt up and really
crucial Hills down onto the mat pressing
against the mat flattening your lower
back flattening your back and just look
between your legs okay if you can't
bring your heels down what you can do is
do walking dog okay so bring your heels
up and down one at a time very good and
now let's step your right leg forward
and let's get into a hip flexor stretch
good what I wanted to do is just to push
your hip flexor forward so you should
feel your left hip flexor being
stretched out okay so push your body
weight forward and feel your left hip
flexor alright
so it's like a lunge position but
resting your knees on the mat very very
good keep stretching good and now let's
get into glute stretch bend your right
leg okay 90 degrees and just reach
forward go as far forward and as slow as
you can you should feel your glutes
being stretched out if this is too
difficult and then start here okay
eventually inch forward little by little
and again relax the upper body breathe
into your muscles that's how we can keep
stretching very good and now what I
wanted to do is just get up and let's
switch side so left leg forward and now
the focus is to stretch on your right
hip flexor
again just lean and push your body
forward very good and just relax if you
want to you can even stretch up and
breathe in okay stretch up and reach up
to stretch your upper body as well very
good now let's repeat bend your left leg
okay good stretch and reach forward the
goal is to bring your glutes your butt
muscles down and pushing against the mat
very good and just relax your upper body
okay little by little and the next
stretch is to get into a side stretch
so these are all static stretches all
right good now push up bring your both
legs forward bring your right leg across
and just twist and look the opposite
side okay keeping your back flat and
look the opposite side feel the side of
your body being stretched out very good
stretch it and just twist and look as
far back as you can keeping your back
flat and support with your arm good the
other way so left cross and just pushing
keeping your back flat filling the side
being stretched out very good keep
stretching breathe in and breathe out so
avoid any bouncing movement keep going
few more you should feel that your heart
rate is slowly coming back down all
right now I wanted to split slightly
okay just spit as far as you can you
don't have to push yourself and all I
want you to do is stretch and reach the
opposite side okay so what you're
stretching is your hamstring on your
left leg and also the side of your body
so just stretch and reach again it is
not about forcing your body it is about
listening to your body and just going as
far as you can and as you practice it
and do it at the end of the workout
every single day you will be able to
stretch further now let's go the
opposite side all right good do your
right hamstring being stretched out very
good keep going just relax and breathe
in and every time you breathe out of
when you can go deeper so as you breathe
out try to stretch a little further very
good keep going
and next we want to do some upper body
stretch so just sit in a comfortable
comfortable position and just bring your
left shoulder across and just stretch it
out okay this is to stretch your left
shoulder again keep your body up upright
don't hunch just keep your body upright
and maintain this position stretch your
left shoulder good and then you know it
do you the opposite side and now change
right and just stretch it across for
those of you who do not do a lot of
stretches you will find that oh my god
every part of my body is so tight that's
why we have to stretch and stretch it
will also help to increase flexibility
if you want better flexibility if you
want to avoid any unwanted injuries
stretch at the end of your workout okay
it's really relaxing as well good and
the final stretch will be tricep
stretches
okay so left across I want you to sort
of like pull it back okay
reach and just feel your triceps this
part being stretched out okay so reach
and keep your back straight as well good
all right no tension reach and stretch
pull on your elbow good keeping your
back straight stretch and now let's
switch and change side
very good again remember pull on your
elbow and just reach breathe in and
breathe out
good keep stretching one final stretch
and slowly release your arms well done
so now I want you to just take few deep
breaths okay so just breathe in and just
sigh out good again breathe in stretch
up one last time
really loud side let's go breathe in all
right guys well done so that was your
cooldown okay
remember do not skip your warmup do not
skip your cooldown every time you do
your warmup you will be able to perform
better because you're prepping your
muscles to push even further and even
more intense and again don't skip your
cooldown you will notice that your
muscles will recover faster and you will
feel better after you do your cooldown
so play this video right before your
workout pause it and then play it again
right at the end of your workout don't
forget to check out my other workout
videos right here like this video share
this video on and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos a lot more workout challenges and
also recipes and turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I upload a new video
all the best